la parole est à monsieur eric straumann
merci de ce président monsieur le
premier ministre
on vient d'apprendre à l'occasion du
dernier congrès des régions de france
que les régions vont gagné 3,9 milliards
du produit de la cotisation sur la
valeur ajoutée des entreprises au
détriment des départements avec
l'explosion des dépenses sociales liées
à votre politique économique qui ne fait
qu aggraver le chômage
nos conseils départementaux vont devenir
de petites grèce en puissance
le président de la république voulait la
fin ministre hâtive des départements en
pratique vous avez décidé de leur mort
financière plus généralement l'opinion y
compris chez vos amis politiques
commencent à prendre conscience de
l'ineptie de votre réforme territoriale
il suffit de lire le titre d'un mensuel
économique moins de régions plus de
dépenses
la moindre réunion de quelques heures va
devenir un véritable une véritable
expédition à travers ses immenses région
avec une hémorragie des coûts de
déplacement et d'hôtellerie pour que les
élus et les agents puissent s'y rendre
le président du conseil régional du
limousin
la firme la vérité c'est qu'on ne va pas
faire un sou d'économies au contraire
les dépenses de personnel vont augmenter
il faudra notamment s'aligner sur le
régime indemnitaire de la région où elle
est la plus favorable
monsieur le premier ministre revenait
sur cette folle réforme qui va
précipiter nos collectivités locales
dans une grave impasse financière
la parole est invendable marylise
lebranchu ministre de la
décentralisation et de la fonction
publique
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
sans doute n'avez vous pas assister à
nos débats puisque tout au long des
débats votre groupe politique a demandé
qu'il n'y ait plus de pouvoir en termes
d'économies pour les régions le sénat
qui a le sénat qui a dans sa grande
sagesse demandé aussi qu'on transfère un
certain nombre de compétences bref tout
le monde dit la région doit être le lieu
de la stratégie industrielle du
développement de l'innovation de
l'internationalisation des entreprises
et de l'augmentation de notre pib
vous croyez sans doute rassembler les
électeurs hors disons qu faut tout ça
doit se faire sans finance il faut un
certain nombre de finances pour régler
ces grandes questions du développement
économique de la france quand vous nous
dites il ne faut pas augmenter il faut
laisser l'entièreté des ressources au
département il ne faut pas diminuer les
ressources aux collectivités de base dit
communes et intercommunalités il ne faut
pas augmenter
peut-être autant concept bref bref bref
j'ai envie de vous dire monsieur vous
nous demandez de de baisser la dépense
publique mais dans la même séance vous
demander de garder les dotations aux
collectivités locales vous demander
d'essayer de d'aider les agriculteurs à
payer la grande difficulté qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui vous nous dites dépenses
dépenses dépenses dépenses et nous on
vous dit économie économie économie
mutualisation des services ont prévu
sierra monsieur avec l'aide des
présidents de région avec l'aide des
conseils régionaux on réussira monsieur
a été ré pme de notre pays parce que
nous aurons un peu nous aurons même
beaucoup de chance d'avoir des régions
fort alors je sais que vous êtes
toujours opposé aux grandes régions
je sais votre position dans votre région
mais soyons ensemble raisonnable est-ce
qu'il fallait une nouvelle en renier son
territoriale de la république
oui fallait-il qu'elles soient
équilibrés oui les régions tel effort
oui monsieur